have camberells are you sure about that
I mean you were in there for a long time
because what they said to me was that
their terminology of average
compensation was tied to pension the way
they figure out their pensions and as
opposed to average salary that you know
the final salary did you get that
clarified
yes and so that's why I'm saying this is
the section average final compensation
shall mean this is the part of law that
defines what average final compensation
is and if you look at the amendment to
House Bill 250
that's what that's the phrase we're
using
right so I am pretty sure about it
um we've just delayed everything yeah so
um
House Bill 250 average final
compensation and you'll notice by the
way in the in the amendment to House
Bill 250 existing law for group one uses
that same phrase average final
compensation so this pair this you know
this set of this section of law says for
group two average final compensation is
this for group one average final
compensation is that and they're very
very similar they're not different in
the way that they're talking right so
um you know
I'm very I'm very sure about this one
um but we're we're you know we we have a
an extra week now because of the delay
so
um we could get an official word from
Marty or something like that if we if we
want to right well I see you're still
alive so they must have agreed with you
right
so there's a fire over in his hometown
nobody's putting it out
but but they may have a point with
regard to 436. right so my intention
with the amendment to House Bill 436 was
to take away was to change the
three-year thing to five years right but
not to change the whole basis of the of
the calculation right so it was to be
anti-spiking but it seems like at least
what they think is that
is that it's not really they're not
really getting their highest three years
or five years they're getting something
very different than that and so
to answer that question we really do
need Marty I think
um and I sent him an email I don't know
if he's responded yet but
Melissa Mike any comments
I will follow up on this I did send
Marty an email on 250 because I know we
sent him the amendment we had gone back
and forth with it but we I gave him the
official Amendment a few minutes before
he had to leave so I just wanted to make
sure he agreed that it worked as you're
you intended I haven't heard back yet
we've kind of been going back and forth
but as soon as I know I'll let
representative McGuire know to confirm
that
in some sense
this is not
um it's not crucial right I mean if we
agree in principle to putting 436 in the
budget we can certainly do it and
there's lots of time before the budget
becomes law to make changes to the
section if it turns out that that it's
it's inappropriate or whatever I mean
even after it passes the house it's got
a whole nother bite at the Apple after
the Senate and so on so
um you know if this isn't right now and
and we can't be very certain about it we
can just take the first amendment that
they gave us uh last last week and do it
that way you know so
but
I would like to do it my way if it is
right
all right
um we'll try to get some answers because
I heard from folks too after your
meeting and they disagreed with your
interpretation so
maybe we can get that squared up
tomorrow morning
um
anything else we'd like to take up while
we're already sitting here
sure
I mean I think I guess the first thing
was we had made an inquiry about the
granite Place Building whether there was
any possibility of arpa funds I don't
know if you've heard back from them on
that
I have two emails out and still no
response yet back okay and then the
other thing was in hb2 do you you guys
remember we took the 40 million dollars
out and then we left the 10 million and
we removed the words and constructing we
just had designing and so I was a little
uncomfortable just sort of making that
change without checking back with the
Department of Corrections and
um Mike and Melissa did check back with
them and they did have some clarifying
language and I don't know if you have
that
if people would give me a second I'll
look up your email and then I can it's
not complicated and we could just get
rid of this issue so
um let me just look
um
Mr chair can I yes okay so what John
Hanson said was that he would suggest
adding the language as follows
preliminary design and complete site
survey and he explained all the things
that that would allow him to do so I I'd
like to suggest that we are a little
more precise in how the money is going
to be spent and change the language as
suggested by doc because right now all
it says is designing
Mr
Hoffman can we prepare something
okay okay thanks
so excuse me since we were given a brand
new
document of seven pages now with what
we've already accomplished
uh I believe Mr Hoffman or Melissa
passed it out just before we went
to lunch and there are a couple of
things that
we might be able to whittle down if you
have that document in front of you does
it have a date it's uh was it's dated
the 20th what's that one right there
so everything on the first page has been
addressed
so we go to
section number four
there's a newer one than that probably
that one right there in your hand yeah
so the first page is completely shadowed
out so that means it's all been
addressed so we have
section 42 the historic housing
preservation tax credit we were waiting
for something apparently from Ways and
Means have we received anything Melissa
I have not received anything but I don't
know if we've reached it
I thought I'm not I don't remember which
member
um was going to
okay well
just
look at that real quickly page 18.
oh
let's do cheer I'll be right back I'm
gonna go get my box of goodies all right
thank you foreign
tax implications for State I mean
so for the I can give you an update yes
just because I've been following it for
the Senate Bill 231 which has this exact
language in it they were we were hoping
they would exact last Tuesday on if they
did not org up onto Wednesday they did
not but I believe they'll be hearing it
this week but this the historic housing
tax credit does have an implication
because there's it's a
um a credit against the bet the business
Enterprise tax the business profits tax
the insurance premium tax
uh five million dollars so I believe the
I'm going off the cup I had but I
believe the impact was
3.25 million a year if the full 5
million was given out on a credit and
they were to use that credit against
their subsequent tax periods or
liability okay thanks appreciate it
you're welcome and it was modeled after
the um Community Development Finance
Authority credit
so any thoughts
members
not being ever on ways and means I
I mean I don't have any thoughts exactly
but it says
um it's intent they want to be able to
convert historical structures to better
residential use and it's intended to be
income generating
so it's a housing issue obviously
Melissa you have any idea what the uh
RSA 77a those
taxes imposed by sure that is the BPT
the business profits tax credit okay uh
77e is business Enterprise tax credit
I'm I'm sorry I keep saying credit at
the End Business Enterprise tax and RSA
400a is the insurance premium tax oh I'm
sorry I guess I did hear you say that
too many things floating around in our
represent McGuire yeah so
um this one to me it just seems very
kind of convoluted because basically in
in order to create this fund that will
be given to people who are doing
historic preservation
um we're going to tell businesses that
they can direct a certain amount of
their tax money into the fund and will
pay them back 65 percent of whatever
value they put into the fund right so
it'll cost them
you know if they put in a hundred
dollars it costs them thirty five
dollars in a sense right 100 goes into
the fund they get back 65 on their taxes
and and they actually are it's gonna
cost them thirty five dollars like that
um
you know it might be simpler just to
keep charging them their you know their
taxes and put into this fund however
much we want to allocate to that fund
and be done with it right so
um rather than this kind of circuitous
sure but but you know at some point
that's all part of the incentive that's
involved in you know so I don't know it
just and it also seems like a lot of
paperwork because whoever wants to do
this has to apply to dra saying I want
to do
100 000 worth or something and and dra
has to add all those up and say okay
we have to stop at 5 million so you can
have your hundred thousand you can have
your whatever and you know it seems like
a lot of paperwork involved rather than
just allocating some whatever we want to
put into this fund
well since excuse me since we've already
heard that there is a bill in the Senate
with identical language I suppose we
could as the Senate do their work yeah
let them do something yeah decide later
right yeah
I mean okay with that representative
yeah I mean I I would say that makes
sense especially because we're
tying ourselves in pretzels here and we
have no input from our own ways and
means committee on the decision
so all right so Melissa will strike 42
if that's okay with everybody
so now we go to this invest New
Hampshire
we've talked about this a little bit
it's a substantial amount of money it's
all General funds it used to be arpa
funds
so thoughts
on section 43.
yeah Joe that's right thank you Mr
chairman we had a brief conversation
earlier about this I haven't put
anything into writing uh because I
didn't want to talk among the division
about it so I invest in h is a program
that's more Market based for Workforce
housing or any sort of type of housing
that they can either accelerate the
municipalities approving the housing or
assist the developers through loans to
build it whereas the affordable housing
fund administered by NH housing which is
separate from the state uh is the
federal matching grant program just for
affordable housing
my ID I I have a couple of ideas sort of
layered into hb2 on this area
I think the invest NH there there's a
problem for problematic to me
regarding the grants and Loans to
municipalities and Developers for the
expansion of Workforce housing I think
these programs invest NH and the
affordable housing fund do complement
each other in which the affordable
housing fund and NH housing will
actually look at the developers
portfolio or their sources of financing
and change their allocation at the end
of it based on the use of invest and age
funds in the development I think we
should just focus invest in h on the
grants to the municipalities strike out
the loans to developers because these
are this is essentially any developer
not just Workforce housing or affordable
housing any developer can get a loan
from the state to build housing I don't
think that there's a need for that in
the financial Market I think if it's the
affordable housing project and they want
the loan from NH housing they can go get
the loan from NH housing whereas the
grants from invest in h would be grants
to municipalities to under my thinking
not currently in hb2 but grants to
municipalities to incentivize the
approval process because that's where
we're seeing the real issues is
municipalities will say well the impact
fees that we have or whatnot aren't
going to be able to maintain the roads
from this new project or the water
pipelines or whatnot so let's focus the
grants from invest NH to in in our
version of hb2 to just grants from to
municipalities let the housing fund be
loans so I'd like to make that change
and then also because it has been made a
priority from the other body via the 231
that they have I think we can also then
reduce the amounts for both programs to
help us balance our side of the budget
and you know if the other body wishes to
then increase them back to these levels
they're free to do that with their money
but I think for us we could keep the
programs intact but maybe bring invest
NH down to 15 and bring the affordable
housing fund to 15 as well to make about
a 25 million dollar reduction in this
area
would seem practical and pragmatic to me
and making the fix to invest in age so
that's my idea I'm happy to get that
drafted uh the language drafted to make
that change formally but that's where my
head is that
all right appreciate the work you've
done on this and sounds like a fairly
good suggestion to me representative
grassy yeah and Mr chairman and I you
know I I think what you had started out
sounded like a pretty good idea but when
you came down to cutting the money I
mean housing isn't critical critical
need for the State of New Hampshire and
reducing this amount of money is
problematic I could see you know the
housing authorities money should or the
the New Hampshire housing should stay
there and this invest in age I wouldn't
be as as opposed to seeing us reduce the
invest NH portion of that money down to
maybe a smaller amount but to basically
what you're looking at is eliminating
the whole thing and putting invest in
H's responsibilities
and I'm not sure exactly I didn't
understand exactly if you're going to
put all the responsibilities in in New
Hampshire housing
no sorry so I I would propose to make
invest in h just grants to
municipalities bring their budget line
down to 15 million okay so reducing that
from 30 million to 15 million okay and
then the affordable housing fund not
changing the the statute on our
relationship with NH housing and what
their so their amounts not changing
because I thought you said you're going
to drop theirs down so I would drop
theirs down 10 million uh from the 25
they requested down to 14 million which
is still more than we we have typically
given them in the budget but I think the
thing is is that housing is a priority
in the state and I would hate to see us
reduce their funding I think invest in h
we could drop that down but leave the
Housing Authority where it is just to
show that we are concerned about that I
know you're saying let the Senate decide
but I'm not going to trust the Senate to
make any responsible decisions as well I
think we should we should hang tough on
our side of this no I I appreciate that
but I also I believe the Senate has
passed 231 which includes the funding at
this levels then we should keep it at
this level
so
area if we get rid of the loan aspect
and invest New Hampshire isn't the loan
repayment a way of
renewing the funds that are available
for Grants and Loans so from so invest
in h is fairly new it was created last
summer and this is the second year of it
and the first year it has General funds
um the NH housing has the separate has
really a separate fund beyond the
federal matching fund that we're
investing to for the loan repayments and
like the 40-year financing that they
offer so I know they do we we don't
really have that with invest in h where
their loans are generating future
revenues and even if they were they
wouldn't be generating them for years
can I ask one other question sure so is
is this the way it's proposed in this
document the way in invest New Hampshire
already exists as a program doesn't it
it was funded with the 100 million
dollars of arpa funds
um
so if we change the language of this our
how does that affect the existing
funding I don't know
it's funded by General funds now so it's
no longer you no longer have the federal
requirements on it
yeah I mean now if we do this what we're
doing is we're continuing a program that
we started with the arpa funds right so
I don't know
I mean I think we set the terms of
invest New Hampshire that we were using
the arba funds for so I don't know how
many federal limitations there are on it
I'm just I'm just not sure your idea has
good Merit I just don't wanna
fiddle with something that the gum
that's already functional maybe people
know more about this than I do
I'm sure Melissa Mr Hoffman I
one of the reasons I jogged across the
street was I had a couple of handouts
one from uh former represented umberger
and one from Ben Frost
and I've been hanging on to them until
you discuss these sections so all right
perfect
I'll just say I figured this language
came from the governor in the way that
the program is currently set up
foreign
although I guess it's not in law in any
way right because this all looks brand
new
that's one of the things I think that
what we want to see is is I think that
you know particularly what
representative Sweeney is talking about
is is municipalities
be basically the controller of this this
money by through grants that they can
get to put towards
um you know different types of projects
that are not in funded by the private
sector
and would it prohibit
um government you know like a community
and I wanted to work with like Catholic
Charities to do something would it
prohibit that I don't believe it would
and I think I want to step sort of back
and get into
um
the the truth behind the housing crisis
that we're in
um it's largely a crisis of Supply yeah
right there is not
so to my knowledge and what I've I've
seen uh for the last few years it's not
a funding portion from the private
Equity or or public funds to build more
housing it's not a financing issue
because it's profitable it's a
profitable Enterprise even at Workforce
and affordable housing there are funds
and financing for it the issue are the
incentives to the municipalities to
approve more projects that that's the
linchpin that is actually driving the
supply crisis and and the supply side
problem that we're seeing with housing
in New Hampshire that's why I I would
rather focus it on the incentives to
municipalities to those you know Board
of Selectmen councils and planning
boards to approve more projects that fit
for their towns
that's why I think the state funds and
invest in h should be directed just
towards the grants incentivizing
approvals to plans because I I I'm I
believe that the financial financial
industry and developers have access to
the capital they need if their project
is is good but their projects need
funding based on the approval from the
municipalities and incentivizing
municipalities to build more housing is
one thing that we can do with the grant
program
I agree with some of that I I mean there
are certainly I think there still is a
an affordability standard that maybe
this would help uh achieve Workforce
housing most people at work can't afford
them uh you know that's a problem with
Workforce housing particularly if you're
in the Seacoast area
um and it's it's something that this may
be the proposal that you have may be
something that would be excellent to do
that and I'm also looking at alternative
housing opportunities as well that
municipalities could sponsor whereas it
may not be profitable for a a for-profit
group to to do as well you know there
are other things we have for for
unhoused individuals right now that that
this as a grant program could help out
and that's why I hate to see it reduced
because I think you're going to see 15
million dollars is going to last long
but 15 but I would be willing to go as
low as 15 million dollars as long as you
don't affect the New Hampshire housing
portion of the budget so that would
basically be cutting the invest in New
Hampshire down but I think you know and
you know
umberger's letter here certainly talks
about the crisis in housing as well so
that she certainly supports fully
funding it absolutely Sheriff I may I I
absolutely agree with you 100 I have no
uh reason to believe that the budget
that the governor will sign in June will
have 50 million dollars for housing in
it I just think we can sort of set the
blinders on invest in h to being the
grant program uh and making our math
work better for our side of the budget
knowing that by the time it gets to June
it's going to be restored
so I just well I do want to make that
clear I know it sounds like you know not
as optimistic as you are on that one
that it'll be restored
well the fact that this sentence past
other legislation in the Senate will
have you know likely to have more higher
Revenue numbers than us uh would lead me
to believe that they'd be able to
restore a priority of theirs
but I we're free to disagree on that
this is not a breaker so
so the uh
Ross letter is quite interesting because
it does as you've probably seen there
have never been any federal funds
received
and I thought there had been some
mistake in there but
and also the amount of real estate
transfer tax which I believe is at
r-e-t-t has been helping to fund
the housing fund for um
a couple of years with some substantial
contributions
so
representative McGuire any I I think he
just didn't list the federal stuff well
it says in his letter that there's no if
you look up uh oh his third paragraph
did not receive any Opera funds and has
never received Federal funding
maybe they have a different fund that
they
you know the affordable housing that's
the New Hampshire Housing Authority and
um I think we had oh here's you can see
that in the past what we've done is
we've had general fund bonds supporting
the housing fund there's a couple of
times we did operating funds but I know
just being on public works we did um we
did some Capital Appropriations for it
were those federal funds no no no that's
what I'm sorry yeah the issue as far as
Federal funding I'm not aware that
they've gotten
was the Federal peace
yeah that's we always worked on that
with them because it's loans it's okay
to bond and then loan back right
so Mr chair it's not clear from um it's
not vital that we know but uh it's not
clear from representative umberger's
letter where whether these
um
the money here was flowing to the
municipality or to the developer or if
that would make a difference to them
I don't know I guess I was thinking I
wonder if you made a grant to a
municipality if they would be then able
to use some of those Grant Monies to
work with Developers
if they wanted to use some of the money
to promote something within their
Community I couldn't answer that
question I was looking at it
my only attempt at answering that would
be we would simply make it as a
perimeter that the program was to make
grants to municipalities uh for the
purpose of accelerating the approval and
construction of Workforce housing would
keep that language in
um I want to get into the
the depths of what the grants can then
be used for but if they could use them
in that way I think I think Bea would
have to set up an approval process an
application process for what you know
what a municipality would get per unit
being constructed
could be used for extending water lines
or I think the infrastructure
improvements are the key that
municipality because it's it's always
the you know not in my backyard
um
frame reference where it's going to
increase the impacts to Services due to
a project and so that's where I think
the infrastructure Investments
municidality can make while uh Workforce
housing or affordable housing project
are coming to town for some small towns
that's the key to getting it approved
it's the blockage so many towns it is
Melissa Mr Hoffman did we ever receive
anything back from New Hampshire housing
where we stood or they stood
specifically for the amount of money
that they've loaned out what they have
available I think we discussed that but
do we
ever get anything back I think
representative Sweeney's made some good
points and one of the things
representative McGuire and I were
speaking to some the other members of
the other divisions this morning in
division three
is looking for whatever funding they can
find for some very
important things like home care which is
a it's like a 3.1 percent increase
in home care and they were hoping to
adjust that figure up somehow but they
have no money so they look to represent
the McGuires got the sharpest pencil in
the room yeah
but I think there's some Merit to what
representative Sweeney has said as far
as
changing some of that
taking the developers out perhaps and
putting municipalities and maybe
bringing the amount of money down but
representative Maguire yeah I especially
like
ending the duplicative nature of these
two programs because as we heard can
somebody apply for both yes right I mean
and so that that doesn't seem right so
representative I like to know
um so the governor wants to put 30
million into the invest in New Hampshire
up to now all the money for that program
has come from arpa so what are they
getting from arpa this year do we know
that I don't think anything nothing so
is that why he's so adamant about
putting the 30 million in there that
would be my assumption but yeah because
you know it's hard to assume okay so
being that we know you know how tight
this budget is uh is it reasonable for
us to maybe give him some but reduce
this amount
that would just speaking for myself that
would be my suggestion because that's
what I would like to do and suggest that
any further comments representative
Griffin
there's going to be a lot of Apple money
that's going to run out
and I don't see how we're going to
continue every program
that has been surviving on optim money I
think we're gonna have to be real
careful about that
so yeah reduce it
I do think we heard from the
commissioner commissioner Caswell that
the alpha money has to be spent within a
year or two so perhaps there's some
remaining funds that could be sent to
invest in each I don't know like again I
hate to suggest her
yeah representative Sweeney I'd like to
ask my friend from Rochester would you
be okay with cutting investment age down
from 30 million to 10 million and
cutting the affordable housing fund from
25 to 20 million so it's still a 25
million reduction but it's mainly on
invest in h and the affordable housing
gets 20 of the 25 million
company invest in each other
thank you thank you for the play honesty
all right so that we have a couple of
numbers flying around representative
Sweeney would like to put something down
yeah I'll I'll stick with the initial 15
million for both reducing invest in h by
15 and reducing affordable housing by 10
and striking from invest in h the loans
to developers that were that's in the
hp2 language just making it grants to
municipalities I'm happy to write that
all up and get an actual
Amendment if needed but uh Melissa is
happy to work with you to get that
language to change
sections uh well
43-48 would affect those sections I
would second that motion
all right is there more discussion on
that
seeing yes represent evil yeah
I know what is in your caucus too it's
an extraordinary uh really high priority
in our caucus and I mean absolutely no
disrespect on your efforts or anything
but I will likely vote no on the motion
because I have to go back to my caucus
all right any further
discussions
I suppose the clerk yeah we'll have a
vote on this because it'll be a written
amendment should have passed
remind me what sections
well it starts at 43 as far as a
subdivision for invest in age and
travels down through 48.
even though those are effective dates
which probably won't change so it's uh
moved
second by candles
do you mind just repeating it um
is it 15 million and 15 million 15
million okay so it's 15 million and 15
and then removing the availability for
mute
developer loans in invest
all right are we all clear in the
language seeing that we are any loans
right this this will become strictly
granted oh I'm sorry okay sorry so yeah
this is just so investment would just be
grants to municipalities okay remove
developers entirely and it's just going
to be grants to municipalities is that
right yeah
okay when the clerk is ready
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes
grassy no
representative Hewitt
votes no representative leishman yes
all right Mike and Melissa if you could
prepare that for us thanks
I've done what that's a page we have
another page off the
are we still waiting on so Granite place
we heard that there are no Opera funds
is that I haven't heard we haven't heard
I have not received a response back I
sent a follow-up email uh last week and
still haven't heard anything
if I don't know if you want to just send
one out that we have to make the
decision by tomorrow so
that was in my email I said I needed a
response by today okay okay thanks
so page four we're done page five
Workforce Development
Workforce Development director hold
policy and Rule making committee
Mike Melissa anything
there
that's uh what is that section we'll go
to what 260.
we haven't received anything new on that
um
yeah that would be good yeah
can we have wait for Marty and be here
in 10 minutes
well I did tell the folks that were here
from the fire department and elsewhere
that we'd make a decision tomorrow oh so
you'd rather have them tomorrow but I'd
like to hear what he said yeah he can
certainly see yeah
just to talk about it so we really
understand that yeah Etc right yeah yeah
that's fine
just as long as we're clear we're not
going to be voting on anything right
right
so doesn't this just look like some name
changes updating
it would appear
representative McGuire are you yeah
oh it's yes it's spending they're giving
somebody a break
yeah
it would go from a Workforce Development
coordinator to a director
I mean I personally have no problem with
this considering the workforce situation
in our state
do we have a cost
um
Melissa or Mr Hoffman
I think on the table Charlie gave us
at this point yeah
the memory
I would expect that salary difference
would be 20 000 or less Okay we okay to
check off 260 and 260 through 262.
all right
on page 88.
yeah I believe we talked about this with
the attorney general
I have a handout
attitude
this has to do with distribution
yeah what the victims get
um
from the assistance fund
maybe this was to pay for the extra
person
who
remember there was that extra person
extra attorney or something in this area
we just approved something
did we approve that guy we did it first
take the questions had to do it
costs
okay thoughts
um
is there two people
in three
years
it could reduce the amount of money
received by the victims technically I
suppose but
so
the postgraded password
just because it says 30 it doesn't mean
they'll spend 30 percent I bet the 15
they were butting up against the ceiling
and they just needed more latitude I
can't imagine they wouldn't do their
utmost to get the most good to the
victims
according to this they are spending 30
if you look at the bottom figure
29.5 there you go
all right so representative Griffin
moves this you okay with this yeah
all right just to show a handson
all right thanks
so we did 80 281
oh representative McGuire look where we
just wound up
we did 281 yeah
oh professional life should we do your
first yeah so we got you got from Carol
the two other sections they wanted to
keep
yes
um in my email maybe yes
so we hopefully will have that Amendment
tomorrow not yet
representative McGuire do you have your
amendment to yeah
I want to see here
I saw your notes but so the these are my
notes
okay these are my number
these are my numbers yes for that
section right so so for every section
there's a note here about keep or not
keep and then there's not that many
keeps it's mostly removed yeah
okay right so this this amendment
is remove everything okay okay and and
we have another amendment much smaller
there well not smaller than this but I
mean small smaller than yeah smaller
than the original pages that you know
put back a few things and our basic
criteria of putting back is if no one
has complained about it
if it's not trivial so there's there's a
few things that are just clean up but
they don't hurt anything not being
cleaned up until next year so we took
those out
um
but all the transfers essentially
um most of the transfers we're keeping
in with the one exception being the
interpreters
um which are now transferred meaning
Secretary of State said I don't want
this put it back to give it to OLS no
BLC yeah yeah there's like four of them
the the auctioneers the boxing
um
you know and then it also removes
I think three of the small ones the
itinerant vendors the Hawkers and
Peddlers and the athlete agents now the
athlete agents that was a bill that was
itl'd in the house or wasn't it no it
was the Senate
passed the house and didn't uh
so it was a house position
not this year obviously but yeah you
know
um and then there were a couple of
um cleanup type things
from past house bills past things so so
in the past some things have been moved
into oplc but the but the rest of the
law didn't catch up quite right and so
there's a few fixed is that 655
is that the First Amendment we saw kind
of yeah but but but
um the assessing certification board
had a few fixes the Allied Health Board
had some fixes in that area
um
the the manufactured housing something
or other board
you know
there's a couple like that
um which are really just clean up
they're not well they're clean up and
and in a couple of cases the board is
going from like seven people to five and
I think the governor wanted to do some
of those things because he has to
appoint all seven people and they have a
hard time finding them so we we
um there's just a few of those that we
left
well do you have an amendment for your
suggestions the ones that you want to
look back well we Melissa's working on
yeah but I could read you what it is if
you want oh a representative Sweeney
first yeah my only question
I'd like to see a list of the licenses
we're essentially pulling out because I
understand this amendment strikes out
everything and then we'll restore the
licensing we're phasing out
to me the
we're not going to take we're we're
going to keep the licensing for any
thing that anyone's complained about I
don't know if that that doesn't sit
right with me because people can
complain about everything we do and if
we just you know I understand didn't do
it because we got one email so I I just
want to be able to fully review
ever so more than sorry but more than
yes
exactly right like I want us from the
beginning right and tomorrow you'll see
the one that has the the reason I'm
writing it that way is so that the thing
you'll see tomorrow is the things that
are in yeah as opposed to saying remove
this remove this remove this and we're
going to be flipping through and saying
oh we didn't remove that you know what I
mean it's like
we don't I'm sorry Mr chair no I was
just going to say to representative
Sweeney's Point we've heard from the
acupuncturists this summer in favor in
summer of homes right you know so
um yeah but you know when it comes to
forestry soil scientists all right
electoral paths you know they've all
seem to be opposed so so let me say some
well all right you're probably yeah let
representative Griffin Golf yeah but
there's a lot of groups that in the
hearing that we all sat through Monday
last Monday
there's a lot of groups that that are
being removed there that nobody got up
and complained about
and yes and some of those are you know
and by white and you know we all get
emails and phone calls and everything
and it seems to me like most of the
activity is
limited to several small you know
several not small groups but several
active groups and I thought Edna did a
super super job and I don't understand
why
we didn't take any DNA's recommendations
and amend
amend hb2 based on Edna's
recommendations this this approach is
just wiping everything out and then
trying to put
so
the thing is
what we're running into is
we can't in one day become experts in
this area right and and even though Edna
did go through it in detail they still
have the opportunity via retained bills
and bills next year and so on to do a
lot of this stuff right
um the the the the the issue is and I
think it's just
um as our chairman said we're getting
inundated with complaints we can't make
an intelligent decision on this
complaint versus that complaint for you
know and so on I will say just in
general so
um
because you know my wife has been
on this committee for 12 of the last 14
years and
um
occupational licensing is it is an area
that New Hampshire does not do that well
I mean we have a fantastic legislature
and all this sort of stuff but but we
say yes to a lot of things there's
there's a license for example on this
list
um that only us and Illinois license
these particular folks right
as a reaction to one case in Exeter that
the license wouldn't have fixed anyways
Etc right and so but but there's plenty
of other cases right Foresters Maybe
less than 20 States license them Etc and
we do we have a lot of Licensing and and
it tends to be because we have
non-professional people in our
legislature and and for example
Landscape Architects right we have
Landscape Architects licensed because it
was done by Chuck Morse in 2005 he's in
the landscape business he wanted to be
licensed right or he wanted friends of
his to be licensed or whatever right and
so
um
and and the same sort of thing I've
heard the same thing about why this
profession was licensed because because
one of those was in the legislature and
we you know people come to us and we
tend to say yes right so in general what
you learn in this area is the people who
do the work want to be licensed right
that's true because it it's a Restraint
of competition all right
um there's plenty of studies you know
where they say for example you study
areas where
so for example dentists dentists are
licensed everywhere right but there's
some places where if you're a dentist
you can move to that place and be a
dentist with no trouble and there's
other places where you move to that
place and you got to pass a test and
take take this class and do this other
stuff and it's complicated and there's
some and there are studies that say
Dentistry costs 10 percent more in the
second kind of place compared to the
first kind of place right so the the it
costs us a lot of money to license all
these things okay so all the complaints
we've heard are not from people who say
um
this board you know I had a problem and
this board fixed it for me therefore you
should keep this board they're all from
people who say don't get rid of my board
you know I want to be licensed and so
that's what you know that's just the
characteristic of this of this um field
but I do think it's way too much to dump
on this committee at the last minute and
try to you know make sense of it so
we're trying to cut it down to just all
the super super non-controversial stuff
and you know we'll we'll bring these
things up again next time that's all I
think representative McGuire has made
some good points because one of the
things that stuck out in my mind last
Friday is when representative Ebel asked
the executive director had she talked to
anybody any of the agencies affected by
these changes and the answer was no so
that concerned me that people really
haven't been thoroughly involved that
we're going to be affected by the
changes in this uh the old PLC and I
think representative McGuire
suggesting we remove things the entire
section and then put back the things
that we know haven't been terribly
controversial and apparently this is
your list representative McGuire yes
okay and and they're made and there were
two more I think from apparel today or
they are here Physical Therapy yeah okay
yes all right so these are the notes
sorry let me turn this up so these are
the notes of the things to retain okay
um
so the first one is the assessing
certification board fixes something
there was a bill last year that didn't
fully make the changes it wanted to make
athlete agents were just removing them
simply because
um
no one's complained about it there's
only about three or four of them total
in the state very few States license
this area so yeah absolutely sorry
so on athlete agents what I had seen was
there was a bill that was going to
remove the license it was itl then Edna
then they were talking about converting
it into a study committee and then they
decided because it was covid they
wouldn't go
forward with it so there really hadn't
been a determination one way or the
other did something happen after that in
the Senate
no I thought it was the other way around
it passed the house in the past and then
the Senate killed it well what I saw was
that it was in Tony Lucas had
said so
the
issue there here is that I mean we can
straighten this out but because
because athlete agents are repealed in
hb2 there is a board associated with it
it is under the Secretary of State's
purview and so it's not indicated to be
transferred so one thing I thought is if
if it's correct that
um the athlete agent thing is hasn't
been repealed by anybody either side
maybe at least we could move the board
from the Secretary of State to oplc yeah
it's really can't be much of a board
when there's only no no you know I
understand so my and then my other
question and I don't think it is a board
I think it's just that it's just the
certification kind of thing right you
pay a fee and say I've you know maybe we
can check that out but that leads me to
my next question is are there any boards
that we are leaving behind for some
reason that should be transferred
yes and no so the one board that is
listed to be transferred is the
interpreters
from their their administratively
attached to education the Department of
Education and I think Carol decided
to leave them alone for now
so that one could be transferred and was
in the original House Bill 2 but for
whatever reason the Carol decided not to
move them
so why don't we just start right at the
top okay
so but athlete agents is really getting
removed so there would no longer be a
license for an athlete age
unless we Loop unless we restore it or
whatever yeah I don't I don't know if
sorry to interrupt but I was
just Mr Hoffman I have a bill number I
can give you and maybe we can track the
legislative history of athlete agents
and figure that out
auctioneers this is a move from the
Secretary of State to oplc
so Allied health professionals
right now there's there's a couple of
there's like physical therapists and
speech therapists and a few other
similar things that are under a board
called Allied health professionals and
that board was moved to oplc so there's
like an extra layer there that's not
really necessary the boards are still
there but now there's the Allied Health
professional board and now there's lplc
so it could be just so what this does is
it just makes those individual boards in
lplc without the Allied Health
professional board if you see what I
mean so so that's what this is doing so
tell us what who comes under the Allied
Health profession there's like five of
them and I know for sure it's physical
therapists and there's there's a few
others
um I think
it was in this um handout that
director Courtney gave us
see this one in this big colorful thing
um there should be a page about this
Repose transfer
all right
um yeah
so it's this page Allied Health
governing board
um
16.
um one board to implement procedural
rules for right
it existed but now oplc has the
authority
um it doesn't even list
so this board that we're that's getting
rid of this layer doesn't itself issue
any licenses it was just kind of the
oplc for those other boards if you see
what I mean so that's that's that one
um but if you really want to know let's
look at page
112 Maybe
yep
allies health professional here we go
okay athletic trainers occupational
therapists physical therapists speech
language pathologist and hearing care
providers and genetic counselors so
that's the group
all of them have their own boards
they're still staying they're still
licensed it's just that there's no
extra layer on top of them okay because
that's it's important for Medicare
reimbursement that they have to be
licensed okay
eliminate a redundant regulatory
framework
so that's that one
um boxing and wrestling moved from so
Secretary of State he had no trouble
with that yeah
um
electricians it's just a tiny cleanup
and it allows if you're if in if you've
got experience in the military being an
electrician that can count towards your
experience
when when you're you know to be licensed
so that's what that one is
um genetic counselors that's part of
this Allied Health thing Hawkers and
Peddlers it's currently with the
Secretary of State get rid of it Dan
tell us what I'm sorry represent where
tell us what a genetic counselor does I
have no idea
they're they're a member of the uh of
the Allied Health I'm not going to
answer this one here but I did have a
comment or a question on the the Hawkers
and Peddlers yes and I want to I
understand it's something you're
concerned about
I I mentioned this at the last meeting
we had I don't know if you were here or
not but as a city councilor I had an
opportunity to have to work on a city
ordinance for Hawkers and Peddlers
because we were having concerns about
them in our community and one of the
things is is that the the people that
came in before our committee said that
well why should we have to get a license
here in Rochester and then have to go to
Somersworth and get a license and then
go to Barrington get a license then go
to Dover and get a license
when I can just get a license in the
state we looked at him and said you can
get a license from the state and he said
yeah and we said well go get a license
from the state and then you're covered
everywhere in in the state by
eliminating this what it's going to
require now is that each individual
Community have their own Hockers and
Battlers licenses requirements and
they're gonna have to get a license in
every Community they go to whereas if
somebody comes in and has one license
from the state
they just go wherever they want in the
state of New Hampshire and they're all
set
and that's what the concern I have is
that we're now going to require that
they're going to have to get how many
communities do we have in New Hampshire
you don't have to get that many licenses
all right instead of just one so I would
be that's something I'm very concerned
about I would like to you know maybe
take some time to be able to talk to my
my code enforcement officer and see what
their requirements are now and if
something has changed since that because
and then and then the next one is the
same I I tender and vendors
representative cambrells I know this is
kind of a on you no that's a good point
I mean uh I was hoping that when they
remove it from the state that the that
the towns would not have a hawker
Veteran's license after that either
because the RSA is removed most of the
towns use the same RSA I believe to do
the hawkrum Peddler's license so killing
it here should kill it in all the towns
that was my understanding and that's
what I would want because I faced that
situation now I run uh charity Raffles
and when I'm in Boston I got to go to
Boston if we're having the meeting in
London I got to go to Loudoun it's and
it's CLI and I gotta always remember
what town I'm in when we do the drawing
for these Raffles because if not I I'm
in violation and uh and it's ridiculous
especially for these charitable events
to have to pay thirty dollars every time
for our license that's what you have to
pay each town so my understanding was if
we kill the RSA
the towns have nothing to hang their hat
on this is RSA 320 and 321. yeah are we
killing the RSA that's the thing and so
that's okay yeah okay so but let's see
here so correct again correct me if I'm
wrong but I thought I could then go to
my town and say hey this has been killed
get rid of your paperwork because all
your paperwork references that RSA and
it'll no longer exist all right let me
look sure
so representative Cambridge do you have
any idea I don't
um why this law came into place was it
to try to control people that were out
pedaling and talking their goods
by my understanding and you probably
have a good understanding to
representative grass he was you know you
get a lot of transients to come through
and they would set off shops to do
certain things and uh to sell certain
Wares and then the the cheat people and
they'd leave town and and again I don't
know at least this made them go through
the motion of applying for a uh a
license to do it and it may have just
been a revenue you know stream Creator
but I'll defer it to representative
grass yeah the experience we had is that
people were coming to town that you know
many times and occasionally criminal
records and they were there scamming
people I mean you used to have a lot of
door-to-door salesmen that were out all
over the place particularly magazine
people would come in sell subscriptions
and descriptions would never show up and
or sell books that weren't what they
said they were going to be and so by
doing it this way we were able to get
rid of scammers in some sense that you
know if somebody was out there selling
we could pick them up and if they didn't
have a Hawkers and Peddler's license
where they were had been checked by
someone in the state then they were in
violation and we could boot them out of
town or you know find them and put them
out of town and but you know that was
one of the things my committee said you
know if somebody's checked you we don't
have to check you a second time one
license for the entire state would have
been the best thing to do then as you're
saying have to pay in each individual
town that was kind of ridiculous and I
just want to make sure that if you're
going to be removing this that it
doesn't give the opportunity for
communities to still do that because
some communities will say you're still
going to need a Hawkers and Peddler's
license so that we make sure that it's
not going to be and I think you know so
at least people are checked for criminal
backgrounds right as well so the answer
is this does not affect the power of
towns as far as I can tell this is
simply moving what the state does in
this area
um
so uh so you still could
require 50 100 and how many rounds are
there different licenses so this doesn't
solve your problem in fact I think it
makes it even worse okay so are you sure
that the town wouldn't wouldn't double
dip and not only require the state
license but the town license we didn't I
don't know what other towns have done
but we've said if you've got a Hawkins
met the requirements yeah so if we
wanted to do what you described there is
a part here
um there there is a line you could
remove here that only to make it only a
state license and not a town license
right but again maybe that's better as
another bill okay that's what I was just
thinking maybe it's better as another
bill and that I would be happy to work
with you on this to get it straightened
out for next for next year do you recall
what the cost of the license at the
state level is I don't
um well the main thing is you've got to
have a surety bond
okay so the annual license fee renewal
is fifty dollar fifty dollars a year
plus a surety bond and they've never
they've never had an experience where
the surety bond was needed so you know I
mean there's a lot there yeah
I guess that's the point as far as this
whole exercise is we're finding things
that we could have let's say unknown
consequences unintended consequences
okay
um mechanical licensing board there was
a just a very minor
cleanup section that's still going to be
a board Etc same with departments but
this repeals the State Board of Fire
Control
on section 430.
section 430 page 154 and I don't know
much about it but it does repeal a board
that we don't know much about
all right we calculations
representative Griffin I'd like to make
a general comment
we're in over our heads here right yeah
yeah
no you know the governor
the government
created a budget he's a piece of State
executive
uh agile
our job is to see whether the funds are
there
to
um
to make the budget work and now we're
getting into
all these licensing things and and
they're really policy things and I think
we did the right thing when we when we
sent the thing to uh Edna and they
certainly addressed
the issue of the groups that had the
Elijah's feedback on the governor's
proposal
but
now we're down yeah and now we're down
looking at every line of it
against the tight deadline
and my fear is that
we we don't know what we're doing in
certain areas
and that we're going to make it we're
going to make it worse and I think
that's probably why representative
McGuire and I where we spoke
over the weekend thought it might be
advisable to just delete these sections
and whatever Edna as you suggested
because they had an amendment as you
recall to put this stuff back on House
Bill 655 I think it was and there were
some other things that were very minor
that the Secretary of State said he'd
like to give up but anything else where
we venture could be very problematic in
my opinion and again we're not the
policy committee
but this is in our laps because it's a
house bill 2 issue that we have to deal
with representative Griffin follow-up
well
yeah
we're gonna own this
yeah and we shouldn't own it the
governor should own it the policy
committee should own it
and we're going to own it yeah if we can
do something and we're not really
equipped to deal with it in the short
period of time no that we're looking at
represent grassy I I think the one
comment about that is that when we had
the director of the department that's
going to be doing all these licenses and
she was asked a direct question of did
you talk to anybody about these things
and in most cases the answer was no so I
think the governor just threw a bunch of
stuff in here figuring that we'd figure
it out and I think that was the intent
because what we're finding is is by
removing some of these licenses and you
know just
you know just cob lunches take the whole
thing is we got significant problems
here and by doing this we're probably
creating more problems than solving
problems so I wouldn't say the governor
had all the answers on these things as
well I think was just put all the
in there and we'll take it out you know
let somebody else take it out
well let me represent talk about this
particular section of evil okay what I
was I just want to say that I did ask
representative Carol Maguire if Edna had
gotten through the whole bill and she
said no and she was only able to
represent a couple of things that the
committee had done so to say that
they've actually reviewed it I they
didn't have an opera theirs jammed up I
think as we are so they did the best
they could do Under the time so we don't
really have their blessing at all
well I don't think that's true for one
thing oh really oh I thought it was okay
all right but secondly on this
particular case
mechanical licensing board this is this
board was already moved into oplc and
this particular section when there were
is a cleanup that should have been done
at the time and wasn't so that saying
these are all things it's not getting
rid of the board it's it's getting rid
of it's telling the board you don't do
things that oplc does for you
right so these are all normal things
that oplc does for boards that are part
of them and so that's what that's what
those repeals are it's not repealing the
board or anything like that it is though
reducing the size of the board slightly
from
[Music]
you can see
what does it say here in the window
anyways there's there's a there's a
reduction in the in the board it in oh
yeah
from from two two gas Fitters to one you
know that kind of thing so there's
there's a couple of changes in the in
the composition of the board and I think
that's likely because
uh and and also
this requires that the board hold eight
meetings a year well
um and and it has a quorum of four
members so that stuff is being crossed
out so they can meet it's actually how
long they how often they want to be
rather than by law they have to have
eight meetings you see what I mean
because these boards frequently they're
so small they don't have much work to do
especially when they're part of oplc so
therefore
um they want to meet less often than the
current law tells them they have to meet
you see what I mean so that's what
that's the this is what we would call
cleanup right it's
it's not
it's still aboard they still make their
own rules they still license people
nobody's license is changing all that
stuff but it's it's changing
that they have to be there with a quorum
that they have to have so many meetings
that kind of stuff so did
the chair of Edna so the rather the
whole committee they make a
recommendation on this or is this
um on this particular line I don't know
um I I do think they did go through as a
committee
the whole bill and look for the
highlights but you know on this
particular line section this is such a
minor section from their point of view
I know Carol read this line by line
whether the rest of them did I don't
know
yeah
so um and you noticed um you know Jackie
grota she's been very has has looked at
it in a lot of detail and had certain
specific problems right so anyway but
but you can see this particular section
right yeah there's nothing here right
except making things a little easier for
this particular board
a representative Griffin I think it's
made of a very good point that you know
we could to do this thoroughly add to
his comments to do this thoroughly if we
were the policy committee it would
probably take us weeks at least a couple
of days really because we finally met
with uh
Edna folks on Friday and we're still
wrestling with
you know minor things but I think
when I like hopefully to see done after
uh
I get done with listening to
representative Hewitt but
I think this needs way too much work for
us to you don't have to vote for
anything other than 107. yeah and there
may be some you know some small things
like again the amendment that they put
forward on Friday that we could
certainly incorporate it but going down
and saying you know what uh the pharmacy
board should be even though they're
so-called technical cleanups
look at it I have you know I'm not I
don't know the pharmacy Lisa so I can't
tell you what if that's a technical
cleanup or not but representative Hewitt
please well
I agree that we're in over our heads
I've been
my
email box
looks like it's been hit by a tornado
uh and I've heard from
a lot a lot of people mostly in the
medical profession because I have a lot
of contacts there
and I'm just looking as I was looking at
what uh
we were talking about here
I just picked a place to look for one of
these boards and I looked at a place
called Physicians and surgeons
every applicant for initial permanent
licensure or reinstatement shall submit
to the Board of Medicine no the office
of professional licensurement
certification
and the office of a professional
licensure certification has a lot of a
lot of boards and things that we're
trying to save
the trouble is unless there's something
here that I can't find and if I can't
find it I'm not going to vote for her I
can't guarantee you that
I can't find
where the office of professional
licensure has
members
who are involved in some degree
in the boards and so forth that they are
that they are supposed to be
taken care of in Terms of licensure
I don't mind them having having the
authority to to
look at complaints and and
letters that they get but to to put them
at the beginning of the trail
right
and I I didn't pick a lot of Physicians
and surgeons I ran across it okay
and right so that's a section that is
not we're not contemplating leaving that
particular section
okay so so
from here right so you're looking at
section 437 right right this is the this
is the page that shows you the things
we're considering leaving
it stops at 4 30 and starts again at
484. so 437 is not there okay do you see
what I mean yeah all right the the oplc
is an organization with
um currently 83 employees about to
become 89.
so there's lots and lots of people there
including attorneys and all that other
stuff that do all of the they're the
staff for all these boards right
and they do the work for all these
boards the boards are the the management
they they figure out what they want to
do with their group
but oplc is the ones who actually take
the hundred dollars and give you your
license and they check that you're
qualified and all that sort of stuff
right that's what they do
all right we need to really move along
or representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman before we we vote on any of
these proposals
perhaps tomorrow after we continue our
recess from tonight uh for our meeting
perhaps the other representative McGuire
maybe the governor's budget or policy
director can come here and we can talk
about this a little bit more sure okay
because we're not we're not going to
make a decision on any of this tonight
at least that's my hope yeah there's a
lot since I have to leave you know we
have uh yeah we have
um very little left except this
particular section oplc we've gotten
very soon and that's why Marty is here
yeah 436 so we'll turn over to Marty
because we've got to make it we don't
have to make a decision tomorrow on
those two bills but we should but Marty
yeah can I just ask a process question
so say representative McGuire brings in
an amendment we don't like the amendment
we make changes I mean we have to be
done tomorrow so if we don't like the
amendment we make changes and then we
just basically have to wait until those
changes are made and embodied in another
amendment for us to approve or how does
that work
back up say that again okay so what if
he what if representative McGuire brings
in an amendment that has all these
changes yeah tomorrow and we don't
approve his Amendment but there are
certain things we would like about his
Amendment would it go back to OLS and
redo it and then we'd have to approve
the Amendments tomorrow night or it's
just process I just wondered how it
works well if representative McGuire
comes in with an amendment we'll vote it
up or down and if someone else would
like to offer another amendment with the
things they like we can vote that up or
down yeah but if I don't if we didn't
have it in our hands okay well they can
get stuff to us and then we can actually
later but they would really like us done
tomorrow right we still have technically
till like Friday so we could even get
together and vote Melissa we're just
going to say because they're committed
votes you can vote without having the
amendment in front of you we've done
that a few times on other bills we vote
as a committee of what you would like us
to see then we go and draft work with
OLS to get it drafted to bring it back
to the committee but you don't have to
take another vote you can just vote on
what you expect the language to be okay
because they will see it we'll see the
final language and then we'll send it to
you but we've done that a couple of
times
for further clarify this and I'm
familiar haven't done this it's been a
long time but amending bills amendments
that come to into committee and making
some changes to I think what
representative McGuire has done here is
admirable and it's certainly something I
can support and you know the Hawkers and
Peddlers saying is something I have a
question about but if you're willing to
take the unintended consequences but the
thing is could we change
like maybe take one out or add one in
tomorrow when we're doing it and then
have them draft that Amendment that's my
understanding the way it can be done so
we can basically use his his draft his
his Amendment as the basis and then we
give it to the LBA and work that out
after we mark it up I think that's
that's great because I'll tell you it's
it's pretty satisfactory to me so
all right representative Griffin are you
all okay over there yeah
yeah I just say one thing when I left
Friday afternoon after that hearing it
Edna
right I thought well they have addressed
virtually every issue
that was in contention by any number of
people on Monday and they certainly
addressed most of the emails
the the issues they addressed were the
ones that resulted in most of the emails
and
I was thinking that we were going to
come in this morning
and say
okay let's adopt
e-dnas proposed amendments
on these areas that are in contention
and
be done with it now that's kind of a
simplified approach obviously there
because we all know that there's a lot
in that bill there's a lot in that bill
but
to try and scrap the bill and start over
then we own it and I don't think I don't
think we're qualified on it we're not
the executive branch we're getting into
their area we're not a policy
committee where finance committee
and if if we concentrate on the million
dollars of fees we're going to lose
that's our job see we're going to lose
if we adopt the oplc language in those
250 somewhat sections we're going to
lose about nine hundred thousand dollars
right and and presumably it's going to
be half a million dollars the savings or
something five to six hundred thousand
of savings all right but they'll still
be self-funding but now we're getting
into
wow like we're we're gonna run we're
gonna run the state
I don't think that side job I think I
should obviously I should point out I
mean when when these things come up to
the floor you vote on them you know I
mean we're going to have to ultimately
you do vote on these we're gonna have to
defend whatever comes out of here first
before the division right then for the
full committee and then the house and as
I told Dan on Friday
I cannot support the sections with oplc
the way it is now I just can't and I
won't and I've always if I don't feel
comfortable about something I remember
years ago as a kid when I was an intern
in DC listening to a United States
Senator said I don't feel good about it
so I vote no and if you don't feel good
about something you have you got to vote
no and I think anything that comes out
of here we have to feel good about it
support it as best we can and there'll
be some compromise perhaps even with
this oplc thing like with the Hawker and
Catalyst that we don't all agree on but
I think it needs probably a clean slate
as representative McGuire has put
forward and then we can I hate to use
the word Jerry pick and we can Jerry
pick the things that aren't
controversial and what Edna told us in
that amendment that we saw 655 and make
those changes but the way this came to
us it was you know without saying too
much I think it was a little unfair to
put so much in for us to review in such
a short period of time and then rely on
e-dna in such a short period of time to
get us their recommendations because
this is not establishing the department
of energy as the executive director said
to us Friday this is a lot more than the
department of energy was this
representative Griffin recalls from
being here so
we will move on to this tomorrow morning
yeah Marty sorry to keep you waiting we
have a number of questions that we hope
you can clear up for us and I'll turn it
over to representative McGuire because
they're his amendments yeah so so Marty
when I took out sections two and three
from House Bill 436 the firefighters
beat me up over n Corrections and
everybody else
in the sense that they say their pension
is not based on the five highest years
of service but it's somehow based on all
years of service under current law and
what they want to go back to is three
highest years so can you explain that in
detail I I can representative I'm gonna
I'm gonna take a come in from a higher
level and sort of narrow down because it
is a lot to unpack here we need that yes
so so basically you know average final
compensation until 2011 was the highest
three years of earnable compensation and
our honorable compensation is separately
defined in the statute in the next
um Roman and A1 and 100 A1
um the chain changes were made in 2011
for members who were not vested by one
one of twelve it it on the surface it
changes from a three year average to a
five which is very straightforward and I
think everyone understands you know
typically a five-year average is going
to be a little bit less than a three you
know in most cases
um there was language
uh put in to that section for these uh
non-vested members and future hires uh
regarding uh something called
compensation over base pay so this was a
New Concept that was introduced uh in
2011 and what if that's fairly
self-explanatory it's like you have a
base salary that's which contract says
you know that's you know if you didn't
work any work straight time that's what
you get at the end of the year other
types of earnable compensation over base
uh compensation over base pay would
include overtime
um uh longevity bonuses
um retirement incentives things like
that
um unused sickened vacation time that's
paid out either at the end of your
career or during the course of your
career
um so so some of those pay types were
excluded
um the the unused sickened vacation time
were excluded from earnable comp so they
don't count so so the way the
compensation over base formula works so
this is where uh I can see people
describing is I don't get my true high
five is
um
when we when that person comes to us to
get a retirement estimate or to retire
um you know we're going to count back
from their retirement date and 12-month
increments uh backwards and find the
highest five years in that scenario
whether it's the last five or they're
non-consecutive or wherever they fall
um since um 2011 when the law changed
employers have been reporting
like two lines for members you know
compensation and compensation over base
okay so what happens is
um you know the base pay and you know
doesn't doesn't get impacted At All by
this
um what what it does is we find the high
five years and then we look at the
percentage of compensation over base and
the high five as a total percentage of
the AFC so if somebody was making fifty
thousand as base and they had ten
thousand is
um you know over time or other
compensation over base it's you know ten
one ones
ten thousand out of sixty thousand
dollar totals or whatever that
percentage is
um and then what we have to do is a
second step and this is where it gets
this is actually where it gets confusing
um is then we have to look at all of
their reported compensation since
January 1 of 11. and look at the
percentage of compensation over base for
the entirety of their career since uh
one one of twelve correct I'm sorry and
if the percentage is
higher in the highest five years we have
to apply the lower percentage you know
the career percentage in that high five
so that could knock down you know the
total
um you know pensionable wages that go
into AFC for somebody in their in their
high five and in a super
straightforward not real world example
of this is for instance you've got
someone who is in a position where
they're just working days okay they're
not taking any extra shifts or doing
anything extra and then in their last
five years they're going to sign up for
every overtime shift they can so they
their compensation is is inflated but
when you take the percentage and the
rest of their career including the high
five it's going to be lower than just in
the five because they had zeros for all
those other years another example where
this could hurt a member is if somebody
was on a disability for a year so they
were only getting you know disability
pay they weren't getting any you know
short-term disability not permanent
things like that so
that that's I think where the statement
that it doesn't capture all of your
money or all of your compensation and
the high five comes from is that
compensation over base calculation and
that isn't just specific to the group
two uh members in House Bill 436 this is
all group two members hired after seven
one of eleven and all group one members
um you know who were not vested prior to
one one of twelve but it works the same
for all of them typically the group
tooth is more comp over based just
because of the nature of the work than
you know a teacher that's pretty much a
contract job you know with maybe a you
know a stipend for being department head
so it you know wouldn't have as much of
an impact but it is it is in the lot
consistently for both groups right now
the same way
so if a group two let's just talk about
proof too if they were doing a
significant amount of overtime such as
the what correctional officers are right
so as I understand that many
correctional officers are working 60
hours rather than 38 and a half or
whatever 37 and a half
um they're working 60 hours so if they
only did that toward the end of their
career
with this under the current way we
calculate knock that down take away that
overtime from their pension or no some
of it but not all of it because the the
overtime work the overtime worked in the
in the high five some some of that
factors in but it's it's it's it's it's
against the percentage of the whole you
know last 12 years so you know if it's
okay
um
let me put um actually right before I
came over I emailed you a handout I did
last year on House Bill 1587 which some
folks on this committee may remember it
it modified the group two tier B portion
of the comp over base slightly and it
had an example where if somebody worked
25 years and their compensation over
base
um you know was five percent of their
pay for 20 years and it was 10 for five
years you know
um under under
um
prior law before 1587 that five percent
is what would be able to
apply to the AFC
um last year that added the high five to
the other career so it ends up being
like six percent more instead of the ten
percent but it you know it
it is by far the most difficult
to comprehend and explain
um piece of our statute let me ask it a
different way suppose somebody worked 60
hours a week their whole career yeah
all right
and
is there anything in 436 would their
pension be the same would their average
final compensation be the same
either way except for the three five
year difference do you see what I mean
yeah so so their Mount over base would
be sort of the same if if that you know
that hypothetical person in a vacuum you
know 50 of their salary was a base and
that other fifty percent was comp over
base for the entirety of their career
yes all of that compensation would count
in the pension count because it was
consistent okay throughout the career
obviously in the real world things are
going to fluctuate and people we have
life events that you know prevent them
from working certain times but yeah in a
vacuum yes you know the I think the idea
behind this I think and I think this
comp over base was I
believe it might have been added in
committee a conference on Senate Bill
three I don't know if it was fully you
know vetted through the Committees in
the House and Senate but the idea was to
um we you know not penalize someone who
worked you know their their job their
Community used over time you know to
keep staff down so they work you know
over time and had differentials their
whole career versus the person who only
picked them up at the end for this whole
intention of doing their their pension
and whether whether that actually
did what was intended you know a leaf to
others but that that was sort of the
rationale when this was added
um to the statute by the sponsor okay
and is this a big change if if we kept
this the current definitions for average
final compensation
but did the the change of the
percentages that you know everything
became two and a half percent
is that a large change to the bill or is
that a minor change to the bill
um it is it collectively it probably is
a large change to the bill again in
those sort of hypothetical situations
it's gonna it's gonna impact individual
members differently based on their pay
history you know since we've been
collecting this data in 2012 so it's not
a blanket you know
good bad for him and bad for him it
could be neutral for one and and you
know you know well actually you know
better for the other person so it's
gonna differ and this there's two you
know there's two pieces we're talking
about AFC and that is the most
complicated piece and hard to pin down
the the other piece is the earnable comp
piece
um in the current bill versus the your
amendment that took it out is the
um the definition of a runnable comp for
the unused
um accruals at the end of career you
know that that could significantly
impact depending on the vacation and the
stuff yeah vacation and sick pass
depending on the employer and how much
they allow people to accrue and at what
rate they do it you know that could you
know a three-year average of a thirty
thousand dollar payout adds ten thousand
to your AFC I see you know type of thing
so there's two there's two you know the
two sections you take out work together
in some ways but they both have an
impact on um you know the value of the
benefit that's it so so I would call
adding in unused vacation as that would
be more very clearly spiking whereas
what you described with this average
base thing maybe a little bit less so
does that seem reasonable
um I I will say that the average base
come over base thing a member may have
little control over that some depending
on on their work situation yes so
vacationing uh you know there's
different definitions of spiking that
that you that use of accruals is part of
honorable comp had been in the plan
since the beginning until it was taken
out for non-vested members in 2011 so
you know whatever the legislative behind
intent behind making that change was
that you know you know I don't want to
use the S word or put words in people's
mouths 10 years ago but that was you
know it had been the legal part of what
everyone was doing there was some high
profile cases that led to some
discussions about this
um you know some employers may be very
tight on how much people can accrue and
it's not big change other employers I
remember they change the policy probably
20 years ago but Portsmouth used to have
unlimited leave I'm sure that cohort is
a sort of retired out of the system by
now but you know it it's going to vary
among employers on that how much people
can accrue
represent chembrels thank you Mr chair
I'd like to make a suggestion you let me
know if this is doable since we're
talking about here a death benefit
basically if they die on oh this is not
this is 436. my apologies
we're going to get to that and we have
some thoughts on it okay no apology
necessary this is
so so let me get back to this one yeah
it all of this language
you know total and compensation
can we just use the words uh average
salary or top five years we can't can we
do that
it was much easier to do that before the
comp over base calculation was added
into that that calculation I mean and in
shorthand we still do that and I I think
you know some members have said that's
confusing for them so it was right to
add more language around how comp over
base works but you know again you know
10 15 years ago somebody you know you
know with with the statute and a you
know an envelope and a pencil can kind
of figure out their own pension benefit
because it was more straightforward but
with different pay types being excluded
for different membership tiers in this
comp over base calculation it makes it
more opaque to the member what they're
actually going to end up with you know
um
do you normally send people a letter
every year saying if you were to retire
at such and such a date your pension
will be x what once once a member
becomes vested after 10 years there's a
member annual statement that's issued
they're online you can opt to get it by
mail instead but and it shows a
projected benefit based on the current
you know as of June 30th of the year you
worked if you know type of thing so
um that that is that is something we put
out yeah
all right
um any other well so I have a question
maybe for representative McGuire or new
Marty so the LBA prepared for us to
document date of the 20th on the McGuire
Amendment
0891h where's that
and it says that the increase of House
Bill 436 on that amendment to
communities will be over 6 million
dollars have you seen this document
um I think that was the Pearson
Amendment from last friday08 918 but you
know part of that is some information we
um submitted it it's it's actually
actually it reduces the
um you know um political subdivision
costs from um
uh 14.38 million in contributions to
9.10 so it you know that Amendment
reduced the annual cost to employers
going forward by a you know significant
percentage
okay so this was the Pearson Amendment
yeah there's so many that yeah the one
that capped the maximum benefit at 125
and moved it from 120 to 125 with no
escalator okay so so that that lowered
the rate impact
um on employers for future normal costs
of the bill uh by all uh one percent of
pay payroll
okay
representative McGuire do you have the
latest Amendment what number is your
latest Amendment on 4th 36.
um good question this was uh
hb2 1083.
1083 yeah
1083 here we go
so it sounds like I need a slightly more
subtle version of that
if any at all
um
so Marty while you're here
okay while you're here let me ask you
about let's switch gears slightly to
um house bill 250.
and you you saw the amendment I handed
out today
so one thing they were complaining about
is they say you can't use average final
compensation because somebody doesn't
have average final compensation until
they're vested that's not so is it no if
if somebody either you know
um you know passed away before vesting
or you know was was killed in line of
duty you know two years into the job we
would take the to the salary record we
have and average that is what the AFC
would be they wouldn't get you know
years of zero or anything like that it's
going to be obviously smaller for
somebody starting out but you know
that's happened on occasion because the
um acts of death battle accidental death
benefit is payable you know for a job
related death at any point in somebody's
career you know it could be on day one
um you know the with the non-job-related
death benefit you have to be vested for
10 years to apply for that one but this
this is at any time in the career so if
there wasn't enough this is the same if
somebody started their Public Safety or
public service driving New Hampshire
later in their career and they were
vested by age but didn't have that many
years of service we take whatever years
they have to use the AFC and you know we
don't divide it by three and add zeros
and things like that okay
um now you notice that under current Law
Group ones their accidental death
benefit is based on average final
compensation but group twos are based on
earnable compensation right so do you
is there any particular reason for that
or do you think it's kind of an
oversight I I actually don't I Melissa
can email me about that at midday and
I'm sorry I missed the initial hearing
at another midday commitment Jan and I
were doing a presentation
um so so when I got back to the office I
I looked and I I have a copy of the
original RSA 100a from 1967. that
language is is the same as it was in 67
and so then I went down the hall and dug
into a file and found a statue for the
police retirement just the predecessor
system RSA 103 A3
and that language was in that you know
back in the early 60s as well so so
there was some intent somewhere in the
past for the group to accidental death
benefit to be half of you know annual
comp annual learnable compensation
um so you know it wasn't changed you
know five years ago or anything like
that it's been around for at least 60
plus years
so average final compensation is
generally less than earnable or not
necessarily wait you know
um it it could potentially cut both ways
depending on your if you took a pay cut
you know to move closer to home or
something in your oh I see you know but
but you know generally the you know the
final year of salary and that's it can
include you know uh unused time accrued
time because you can't take it because
you're not with us anymore kind of thing
so that so there's this stuff that falls
into that last year's salary a
three-year average
typically would be probably lower than a
one-year average but again
um that
year of earnable compensation is a
holdover for many many decades and I and
the AFC for group one was in the
original statute as well that wasn't
modified over time either so
um I just think it's better to be
consistent but that's me all right
representative Cambro yes thank you this
is the one that I wanted to make a point
on maybe for simplification if it can be
done rather than getting through all
this gobbley and all this language
this is a death after all that we're
talking about are not all lives equal so
why couldn't we just offer a lump sum
whether that is 85 000 or whether it's a
hundred thousand offer and again this is
a unique thing not too many deaths occur
thank God so why don't we just outright
offer 85 or a hundred thousand dollars
for any death regardless of time whether
it's one day or 30 years of Duty a death
is a death all eyes are equal and offer
a lump sum instead of these stupid
formulas
comment Barney what would that
completely policy decision so if if you
bring that forward we'll run the numbers
but um okay I think the constituents may
have opinions they'd be willing to share
but nhrs doesn't
do you know sure do you know what the
average of the 19 people currently
getting benefits um I I received a
question through LBA last week about if
if the bill was made retroactive
um you know and there there are 19
spouses currently receiving a you know
group two accidental death benefit with
an annual payroll of about six hundred
thousand I forget if it's a little more
or less than this 19 so that's the
average is probably about 30 000 you
know in that range
um you know and fortunately you know
we're blessed that there aren't a ton of
Duty related deaths in either group one
or group two some of these benefits are
small because you know the the death
occurred in the 70s or the 80s or the
90s
um you know and you know we've got a
couple of
um annuitants receiving that benefit or
in their 90s themselves now so they lost
their spouse a long time ago
yeah
so representative cambrell as you raise
it interesting way so this would be kind
of like a life insurance policy that
you'd go out and purchase for you know
whether you get a hundred thousand
dollars or half a million dollars but a
one-time like a life insurance policy
upon someone's death that's kind of what
you're looking at yes I I do want to be
sure uh be careful uh this when we give
this benefit is it annual to the spouse
or it it it's it's paid out as a monthly
benefit so you know does it whatever the
annual amount is you know whatever the
number is they pay it annually for a 20.
annual amount has been divided by 12.
monthly until until they pass away yeah
until death of the spouse or remarriage
yeah
so it seems to me since we've had all
these complicated formulas anyway we
could come up with an average amount
that would be fair to all whether
they're New or Old come up with some
average amount and that would be
acceptable to all and again these are
these deaths are rare so that would be
paid on an annual basis not just a
one-time payment well that's how it is
Into The Spot until the spouse dies oh I
know I thought that's what he said
earlier like a one-time person that's
why I'm correcting myself yes I
apologize because I realize that it has
to be uh uh continuing into the spouse
dies or until the children are uh 18 18.
so and again that's that's rare too and
so it's just that these
goofy formulas that they have you know
very complicated I mean I I learned
English you know and I and I know with
average compensation means it means
something totally different to them and
accidental death means something totally
different to them than it did to me so
um maybe we can simplify this and have
them all come to an agreement yeah that
makes it representative
Salem Sweden thank you Mr chairman yeah
just goofy formulas in my head so 19
recipients around 600 000 so it's about
thirty thousand the original Bill wanted
to really double it so I think that
number that we'd settle on would be
about sixty thousand
annually for any going forward
because it's not retroactive it's
I
that's reasonable yeah it's been you
know yeah all right thoughts on that
seems again speaking for myself seems
pretty reasonable
it's certainly
simple is better hopefully but yeah
representative Griffin you have a
question
surprisingly I didn't find uh
Dan's amendment of 250
very complicated I thought it was pretty
straightforward
see we would take marriage final
compensation all that you know just have
a one-time annual payment it's going to
be rare
and it's not like you're going to be
calculating it every month or something
and
um
it seemed to me like a simple way to do
it what are you going to do you're going
to have people with who are making
you know
I hate to talk about people dying on the
job but they're going to have different
salaries
and I don't know how you do it lump sum
thing I I thought your amendment to 250
was
pretty straightforward and address the
issues
unlike
some of your other amendments
it is getting late now yeah again to
clarify it's not a lump sum it's a sum
that would be divided by 12 and given
out every year every month to the
spouses or the the kids until they pass
away and again I think all lives are
equal value if you died on the first day
or in the 30th year I think it's a
simpler formula and if they don't like
it we'll go back to representative uh
McGuire's thing and and that that turned
out to be a nightmare so
you're going to get quoted
anyway
um is there a figure representative
gambrels that you would like to use or
representative Sweeney for then I like
the 60 that representative Sweeney put
up because it seems to make sense 30 000
average now they wanted it doubled we
give them 60.
I think I think that's fair all right
okay everybody okay with that or show of
hands please
you want to sleep on it
all right
could you prepare that for us thanks
all right we'll call it a day
um unless there's something else Marty
could you please be here in the morning
at 9 30. absolutely sir and I'll
probably repeat the comp over base again
but it you get to sleep on that as well
it it's it's extremely complicated
um I can forward that stuff to you if
you want to forward it to the committee
as well
so I'm reminded that we've been invited
to the governors uh executive Council
chamber tomorrow I think at eight
o'clock eight something anyway we can
all go and see what we think about oplc
representative Sweeney so Jim do we do
we expect tomorrow to take at 9 30 an
hour on the retirement bills then an
hour on licensing then we solve all the
other world problems afterwards
there's very little left on there's some
a few amendments uh are you going to
have another amendment tomorrow for 436
for 436 or are you gonna all right well
we're done with 250 now yeah okay
um we still have 571 we have it um and
you have an amendment for that right
yeah you got two they're both simple I
think but you know
there's there's bicycle at yourself yeah
I guess it's been a lot more simple than
yours right
um on oplc I will get Carol will be here
tomorrow okay okay so
um she can answer any questions about
that
what else so I I will talk to Carol in
detail about 436 okay because I do think
those guys
you know they were sent off but maybe
not
after listening to Marty not
there was some confusion there was a
confusion but but it may not be
justified the level of angst but you
know but but we could maybe come up with
some kind of compromise because my main
thing is I don't want to restore Spike I
don't want them to say okay I've saved
up a year worth of vacation so now my my
my uh salaries twice what it should be
right you know that kind of thing that's
that's the key part of it so
all right Johnny you did you have
something
that you I know you mentioned the other
day there was something with Das that
you were concerned about her but
could you take the mic please
yes
thank you
for the record my name is Jody grimbulis
um I represent a company called workday
workday is an Erp vendor one of many in
the uh in the country working on Erp
systems throughout the states
um there has been several different pots
of money that have been sent to
Department of administrative Services
either through arpa money which is 15
million a couple months ago there's 7.8
million in the house bill 2. we approved
the other day and we have no problem
with that whatsoever the state should
take the money they're going to need to
upgrade the new system and the only
thing I would ask one of the things that
we have talked about a little bit
um is that could it go out for
competitive procurement I think right
now it's being looked at as a sole
source and I guess there are a number of
players in the industry that would like
the opportunity to at least say there
are three years until that system
becomes
um
not functional I think it's April 2026
is what was said in the arpa funds is
that when that system becomes on
um unusable and so if there is a little
bit of time between now and then does it
hurt the state to at least do an RFP or
at least a request for information from
the vendor Community to see what's up so
I have language that would add just a
sentence that maybe that should be
looked at and that is my request
um Melissa Mr Hoffman
you take your language but also reach
out to das please and
there's just a couple copies
seems like a reasonable request the the
main question is was the arpa money
already committed right I mean did they
already make a contract there's been no
contracts it was just an except
they're uh you have until 2024 to
encumber it 2026 to spend it was my
understanding but right but I mean that
was months ago and they may have signed
some kind of contract no contracts have
become before governor and Council yet
okay thank you Melissa Mr Hoffman we
will again reconvene tomorrow here at 9
30. we'll start out with uh
the representatives amendments on
retirement please want that first okay
please okay
all right we'll see uh we representative
lunch tomorrow
luncheon well that sounds good oh you
didn't know we were working through
lunch tomorrow
is that in the calendar
oh okay it's good
we'll try to break at 11 30 so we can
get down we can get be there first
yeah hey thanks you guys really
appreciate your efforts bye